my name is mr. butcher I teach
agricultural practices here at kirinda
State High School we are very lucky to
be one of the few schools in Brisbane
that has a working school agricultural
section as well as having access to a
large area of common land adjacent to
the school agricultural practices is a
very hands-on subject that touches on
many areas of food and fiber production
this includes beef cattle sheep goats
cropping and bees all the course does
have a focus on the management practices
of these many different industries there
are components of transferable skills
practical skills such as machinery
operation and fencing construction that
are very useful in many different
occupations the farm setting also comes
with its own unique challenges and
agricultural practices is a great place
to learn 21st century problem-solving
skills in a real world context the last
point I would make is that this subject
will provide you with fun and exciting
opportunities to experience the real
Australia every week we work outside
with our cattle at Oxley Creek common
which is our own little patch of the
Australian bush in the city what a great
place to learn
[Music]